mon claude montre votre dessin a pas mal
du tout
casimir devant le soleil très bien que
tu continues chantal c'est pas fini ça
chante alain faut continuer l'anc carl
il est fini il tient un se terminer il
est très très bien et que les montagnes
dans le fond et tous les papillons
tiens ça va véronique 1 ça marche
parfait christine oui
thiam entretien olivier bouthillier l'un
l'arc en ciel le soleil et tous les
jouets l'île aux enfants parfaits
montrent les staffs
ah oui celui christophe est beaucoup
plus simple il ya moins de deux mois
d'un autre style oui qu'est ce qu'il ya
à toi qu'est ce qu'il ya bientôt je suis
vos est ce que tu es bout ouais tu es
superbe c'est bon je te le promets je
peux me veux-tu reprendre la pause or là
mais mais mais mais il n'y a pas donné
en un modèle ne doit pas quitter la
pause sous aucun prétexte
bon enfin casimir aurait-il marché sur
un iris n'est pas du tout pas du snob
dans simplement casimir on avait un
petit plat c'est de tenir la pause pour
son portrait ne me dites pas qu'il sert
de modèle pour les peintres mais si mais
si monsieur snob et c'est passionnant
voyons ça garage
extrêmement totalement moderne à quel
dommage que dites vous quand je disais
seulement quel dommage c'est vraiment
trop triste
qu'est-ce qui est trop triste que le
modèle ne soit pas plus jolie quoi qu
avec casimir la pause s'ils te mana
l'écoutant
enfin que reprochez vous à notre modèle
il est affreux en moi casimir la prose
ma voix là vous comprenez pour que le
dessin soit beau il faut bien dessiné
les oreilles et et casimir n'a pas
déraillé alors casimir que si je te
plaît s'il te plaît ne bouchera là
qu'est la bouche suit beaucoup plus beau
que vous même sans oreilles allait
reprendre place
voilà je dois dans la bouche c'est comme
le nez il n'a pas donné ni de ceux venus
même de doter l vous devez pardini
d'énumérer toutes les parties du corps
que vous connaissez que vous dites ça
parce que vous êtes jaloux de moi parce
que je suis né ou plus beau que vous
avec tous vos bonnets vos yeux vos
oreilles vous chers amis il évoqua le
faut je ne connais même pas les parties
du corps j'en ai connaître mieux que
vous
il n'y aura qu'à aller à la fois je vous
en prie monsieur du snack est quasiment
atteint un petit peu tenu bon bah écoute
et on va voir celui des deux qui connaît
le mieux les parties du corps qu'ils
croient que c'est nécessaire françois on
croyait cela vraiment intéressant n'ayez
aucune crainte je vais vous envoyer des
renforts dont les enfants ont fait deux
équipes 1 une équipe avec du snob une
équipe avec casimir lesquels prenez-vous
me suis dit ça donne mais promis les
premiers là alors 4 4 avec monsieur dix
neuf et 4 à 4 avec moi alors
voilà voilà ça y est la leur écoute et
moi écoutez moi bien voilà comment ça va
se passer
chaque écoute net à tour de rôle va me
donner le nom d'une partie du corps
c'est simple c'est compris alors on y va
équipe casimir par aller qui donne une
partie du corps chant et carole carole
et ironique
headley casimir hadley oliveira les
derniers mois une jambe allez une jambe
pour l'équipe de casimir jeu marc
denjean woerth équipe du snav équipe de
snobs une par une corde chose le bras le
bas pour toutes à leur gardien tout à
leur équipe casimir lit alors une partie
du corps la cuc la bouche la bouche du
club jean-françois les yeux
casini attend les dans le nez casimir
aurait eu dans les mains
jean-françois christine carole les pieds
et véronique les pieds équipe du snob le
coeur et les oreilles très bien les
cheveux
une seule réponse garder les autres
après 20 levante bien continuer à l'ailé
le genou le genou
les noix le foie le nombril eudois
puniet arthur vient simplement du garde
les autres plus tard à l'annulaire à
müller ag
la lefp wah wah wah wah wah wah